covas teve uma vida mais um vídeo e hoje
eu vou testar a nova impressora da terra
até outro nada como máquina para quem
quer começar no bumbum impressão 3d
porém que eu vou começar por mim coisa
grande como jarros candeeiros coisas que
ocupam muito espaço e essa é uma
campanha muito boa para começar porque
ela é barata e também já vem quase toda
montada ao contrário das outras
impressoras jogou costa você só tem que
colocar alguns parafusos conectar os
cabos e já estava pronta a utilizar vou
começar por uma caixa fazer essa pequena
vantagem para vocês verem como é e
depois na parte final do vídeo vou fazer
um arco e flecha e mostrar pra vocês
como funciona
então agora vamos começar
[Música]
vocês podem ver que as peças foram
feitas quase todas do mínimo que dá uma
boa qualidade e esta máquina tem uma
caixa que tenha parte elétrica e depois
da placa de circuito que controla toda a
máquina para montar basta colocar os
parafusos por baixo e depois para forçar
ainda mais a conexão precisam de colocar
um ter um lado e um tio do outro lado
sendo que um dos textos um sensor que
travou o envolvimento do zé ou seja
aquela parte de cima vai deixar de
dedicar um sensor tuco no sensor um
movimento para ea partir daí que a
máquina vai começar a imprimir as peças
3d em termos de rigidez é muito sólido
isto tá muito bem construído ea maneira
como eles cruzaram os diferentes bairros
faz muito sentido e dá muita força a
máquina e uma coisa que não tem muito é
que quando vocês colocam aqui os três
laterais neste logo a diferença na
estrutura fica muito mais rígido
eu pessoalmente gosto mais da estrutura
desta máquina aqui em comparação à
última que eu me enviaram até black
widow então eu pessoalmente gosto mais
desta porque parecem que esta é muito
mais robusta do que a outra
apesar de que é do equino tem muito mais
domínio porém as conexões não são tão
boas como as conexões desta máquina aqui
é de começar em primeiro nível e à mesa
e depois no programa roteiro rossi que
já tem instalado no pc
porém se vocês não fizerem ideia que
quer porque rosa e como utilizar nos
preocupa porque os damos um manual aqui
encantado manual explicar como instalar
o programa e utilizá lo
então tá muito bem explicadinho tem
imagens como vocês podem ver coxinhas
apontar quando vocês devem clicar então
não tem nada quem é muito simples por
isso acho que não vale a pena mostrar
muito do software aqui neste vídeo
depois de conectar em a voz em pessoa ao
computador com software lá dentro você
só tem que importar o modelo 3d clicar
em fatiar ou seja basicamente o vosso de
o 3d vai ser dividido por esparguete
depois no final é só clicar em imprimir
como vocês podem ver que o barco está
ficando muito bonito limpinho porque os
próximos modelos vocês vão reparar que
vão ter algumas teias de aranha
então eu fui ver o que está tendo muitas
terras guarani vamos mudar as demissões
então eu fui e aumenta a irritação e
aumenta
ligeiramente a velocidade como vocês
podem ver que nesta imagem
ou seja vocês devem experimentando
diferentes definições até chegar uma
qualidade que vocês estão satisfeitos
ainda inicial é fazer uma campanha
dizendo isto aqui que tem muita força e
acredito que consiga mandar flechas
é mais ou menos 50 metros de distância
foi dissipada 45 graus
a iffhs o 3d é pensar que utilizar isto
aqui mas depois quando eu tiro as coisas
que eu tinha feito em 3d no programa
para imprimir vir aqui morar mais ou
menos 40 horas o que é muito tempo então
eu pensei vou fazer uma versão em
miniatura para ver se funciona bem
esse funcionário depois de que um mês
dois três quatro no site é falso uma
versão em tamanho real
agora vamos ver como é que isso vai
ficar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a idéia inicial era fazer um arco mongol
porém quando eu jogava o filme war
desdobrava ao contrário procure se eu
podia ter as palmadas tubos pvc e da
reforma que cria
porém como não tem nada para aquecer os
tubos cá dentro então pensei bem é mais
rápido que eu cortar aquela parte
central e fizer o outro modelo 3d em que
fique com aparência de um arco normal
seja um ar clean ou então um arco em
inglês usar que os ingleses eram os
london velho lobo começa também
[Música]
e pronto aos campos o fim e espero que
vocês tenham gostado deste vídeo aqui
se estiverem instalados em comprar este
empresário o link vai estar na descrição
texto filho e se tiver alguma sustentar
um projeto que vocês gostariam que eu
fizer as coisas na impressora 3d é só
deixar nos comentários
eis muito obrigado até a próxima